hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the stranger I'm not
gonna pretend like I know a goddamn
thing about this game because I
absolutely have no idea wires rain going
up okay anyway like I said I don't know
anything about this game
hi Lyra hello why am I in the gay with
Illuminati hi Oh another one let me
guess you're here to find treasure or
some nonsense like that guess what no
treasure in this place not even a dime
might as well just lay down and go back
to sleep
skulking squatters they call me head
wall I call you a Luminato consider this
my warm welcome ok
ok goodbye well we are off to a riotous
start I have no idea what I'm doing and
I'm just as confused as when I started
this but supposedly yada yada yada
highly-rated so hence why I'm playing it
ah oh ok
a little confused but it's beautiful
reminds me a winwaker oh hi hello please
tell me you're a squirrel because I
think I'm king of you hey you yeah you
with weird hey don't make fun of my
bulbous Lea huge head I know I have an
enormous head don't worry about it
you think you're big enough to roll with
a bone squad I can make many a bone joke
but my brain just ain't up to it right
now
who's the pone squad well huh I'm in it
I can tell you that much and you can be
to providing you could show me how you
hold up to in the paint make me proud
jammers uh think I'll I'll think of a
better nickname later after you're
officially in here's a ball don't lose
it it's our last one ok I'm a little bit
of what the hell just happened
oh hey Oh God extra plus ball not for
use by humans or animals hi oh that
didn't work
Oh God bone begley familiar ah come back
here ok
anyway this is gone horribly awry ah too
much power ha Bisky
[ __ ] we're like a beach ball or a
kickball than an actual basketball here
we go
wah wah wah wheel mm shove us key oh I
didn't go in yeah close enough thanks
man
meet me upstairs we got to discuss your
initiation well I don't even know if I
want to be part of this club I I
literally just walked into this island
from a cave that I apparently teleported
into and I'm apparently dreaming I have
no understanding of anything that's
going on or why I'm here but yeah sure I
want to join your bone Club first I'm
gonna get this in here I'm a winner I'm
not a quitter I'm a winner I'm a why oh
man I could have got that in if I just
got another try gave up before I got
there and why is this bone familiar to
me why would this bone be vaguely
familiar and also what's going on in the
background over there I'm so I've I fine
I thought I had questioned reality just
a little bit too much and it decide to
all collapse on me but you know i'ma
stop lollygagging and I'm gonna try to
actually get up here really do ski some
items you can interact with after
pressing a again decorative earn it's
pulsing with dead life maybe we should
rub it I rub the [ __ ] out of that
oh hi hello boo did I get you you look
pale don't worry about it happens all
the time
okay who are you do you have a name okay
you're just gonna alrighty then
you know what I'm gonna go along my way
and the disturbing penis ghosts over
here can just haunt that little realm a
reality while I try to join the bone
squad it's it is this just like a like a
game interpretation of an actual dream
because this is awesome look every part
of this is amazing
all right you knocked that one right out
of the park I mean that was a real
touchdown you're real Gretzky in fact
that's your nickname from now on Gretzky
okay until I get bored of it or think of
a better one
welcome to the bone squad is this like
them is this like what was it called is
this like the boner cast a radio show
that we talk about all the time our
personalized podcast talking all about
boners all day all along all night a lot
all long boners all day all night all
long hear it owner cast well that wasn't
the name of it yeah it was the name of
it why am i questioning myself I just
looked it up it was the owner cast
welcome to the boner cast tell us about
you boater no okay all right I'm sorry
as a member you get full access to the
island don't let any grumpy floating
older than time guardians of mystic
whatever tell you otherwise say speaking
of which I've got something wicked
awesome to show you it's on the other
side of the island a bit of a track but
totally worth it
why don't you get going and I'll meet
you there I've got squirrel stuff hey
you are a squirrel hey I'm the king of
that thing that you is see you soon
Gretzky no Martha Stewart no Obama okay
all right once you decide what you're
gonna talk about I'll come back to you
rule
oh well I did a thing there holy [ __ ]
who knew that I had such power is that
because I'm part of the Boehner squad
the Boehner cast for the bone Squad
I'm gonna call it the boner boner squad
it's me President Obama this is my Obama
impression here too
oh okay all right then Obama going up
the hill now don't know why I'm here or
where it is beautiful
also that music is pulsating and funky
hello can you come back down here for
Obama thank you where the hell am I
going but I can run yeah this game is so
weird I found it on I found it on
gamejolt but it came out like last year
but I just oh a tiny perfect obelisk
it's so tiny it's so perfect it's tiny
obelisk Oscar it's it's it's all blah
gobble it's oblong obelisk Oscar all
right good job being a novelist coming
to put you down now ray obama has the
power
how about move I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make it I'm not
gonna make it Obama's not gonna make it
I have a good thing I got this obelisk
here he aie digging yeah okay all right
I got it
cool still don't know I'm here but
Obama's gun up he pressing on Oh what
happened to my obelisk and what happened
to my I had an obelisk I didn't know
what to do with it but I had it and I'm
gonna go back can I go back okay I can
go back now obelisks better be there Oh
God
hitting my nipples god damn it that
didn't make any sense at all why was i
teleported all the way back here I don't
want to do this again what a low to acid
tree all right I'll be back
apparently hmm what
oh you dick hitting [ __ ] nut you sack
of [ __ ] bags what is it did I broke it I
broke the goddamn game didn't I oh I
[ __ ] broke it hard I broke yet your
Burpo derpy derp don't know what the
[ __ ] did you well there we go
now it's gonna well shitty dicks Oh No
there we go okay this time not gonna be
a bag of asses and this time I'm gonna
get oblong obelisk Oscar and do a thing
okay so does this belong anyway
well alright at least that corrects my
mistakes for me this is going anywhere
hello
glug glug [ __ ] alright in I guess it
doesn't go anywhere why'd I get a tiny
obelisk okey-dokey then
so I'm just gonna take this I guess this
was nothing this was a whole lot of
nothing hi I looked around I can't go in
the wall wall I have to just keep
pressing forward okay I can do that hey
buddy hey buddy this looks weird and
you're probably gonna make me worship
something or someone hello hey or Jordan
thanks man how's it going oh pretty
pretty nice so I got to admit I have
like no clue where that spot I was
looking for was I thought I had it but
then I lost it
we can still chill right let's shellac
still the dogs come home talk about each
other's boners you don't seem super
interested in that yeah maybe we can
still find a spot then you somewhere
around here maybe if we just look around
you tell me if you didn't look around I
mean I found a novelist before but I
don't know what that was in regards to
so I'm just gonna carry on and assume
that I know what the hell is going on in
this beautiful landscape of Horrors cuz
like most games I'm going to assume this
is all gonna turn dark at some point in
time and I'm gonna die oh yeah probably
in there oh I have a funny feeling I
gotta step into that thing's mouth which
is usually Pleasant but in this
circumstance I'm gonna assume it's gonna
be bad for me
what about over here it looks like a
secret path into something hello oh [ __ ]
please don't teleport me back ah good
hello hmm usually this thing here is all
glowy but as soon as you showed up it
just shut down maybe you have a disease
hmm whatever it is we can't get anywhere
here unless this thing is all lit up you
probably got to go somewhere else and
get blessed or whatever oh oh so this is
the point in the story where I gotta go
sacrifice a virgin or whatever and then
come back you're coated in the blood of
a goat so I'm gonna do those exact
things you can't talk me out of it I'm
already on my way I got the goat I got
the virgin right here uh all right what
do I do
well I gotta go get blessed ah papa
bless me papa I find a yachty where this
isn't the same place that I came out of
is it oh maybe it is hello who the [ __ ]
are you hi hello okay yes hi yes okay
you're not from here right you smell
like a wave place is far and maybe
bagels you on some big-time quest for
silks and spices friend how much of that
stuff around here mostly just dirt and
squirrels he's no friend like you snuff
big old buddy big as me even he wasn't
scared of the dark though he made me a
nightlight with magic probably big old
snuff went missing some mad fortnight's
ago friend got lost in some mad modos
soaking in the dark spots I think it was
a nice guy
to be careful when you're soaking with
the Mojo's okay they can't get you silks
and spices friends just bad directions
are you talking about this magical
squirrel that's telling me to go get
blessed in the blood of a virgin and a
goat possibly a virgin goat I'm not
entirely sure about the circumstances of
that but I'm gonna go do that anyway
because I don't trust you actually I
absolutely trust that guy he seems
amazing okay I gotta admit now that I
actually had a chance to wrap my head
around what the hell is going on here
this game is legitimately cool it's
super well made this game was free by
the way
it's just kind of a trip here it makes
good use of its visuals and limited you
know resources what not wise is here
where's our bowling pin
where's our bowling pin hello hey
sweetpea
doing a little adventuring and exploring
it you're really taking this looking
around thing to heart you could get a
lot higher if you had a grappling hook
or stilts her legs made of Springs like
a majestic gecko Steve his name is
sunshine I'm beginning to think that
you're crazy and I should probably keep
away from you I don't think you want me
to get a grappling hook I think you want
to get me dead
and then probably steal my soul no uh-oh
where am I now I don't know where I am
oh oh my goodness what is this now hello
I've come here for spices and possibly
to get blessed what is that do I want
that it looks like I want that
it's a disembodied hand oh no its glove
yay I got a hook shot oh man is that you
foxy foxy second son this week okay
sorry about that friend well I'm gonna
take your robotic arm and I'm gonna use
it to my own personal advantage how do I
get out of this pit oh it's a teaching
thing oh it's an educational mold how do
I like why have it equipped I'm not
learning hard enough there we go okay I
don't think I was supposed to do that I
think I was supposed to learn how to
hook but it did not happen oh yes I was
okay hey nice gizmo hey nice creepin
around the corner like that you frickin
weirdo look at you being all gangster
stealing from the dead like that he
wasn't dad he was talking to me don't
worry about it
that robot will probably miss his arm in
the afterlife whatever though looks way
cool mind if I give it a spin huh
okay mob rule Finders Keepers
see you later Home Slice I don't like
you you seem weird and creepy and
probably trying to kill me like I said
god I love this music love the
environment I love not knowing what the
hell's going on
are you gardener overtire Bhagu but dude
why is our keyboard here
hell yeah hell yeah pop oh I shouldn't
have done that bought a jump MIT jump
okay hey you I nice nice oh that's cool
that's cool huh
oh that's so cool oh that's so cool the
mechanics of this game are actually well
thought out this game is just free so
cool
hiyo silver all right where the hell am
I going now
hello God it seemed to just be
traversing nothingness also what what
was that about getting blessed I'm back
here now oh good
Oh where's I see a target over there oh
yes oh yes hell yeah okay now we're up
here oh that's so cool that's neato
that's neato kebede oh that's so sick
I'm trying to use new lingo besides cool
and I don't think it's working for me
but either way trying hello are you
gonna bless me pop a bum well [ __ ] I
feel blessed
have I been blessed I'm gonna assume the
answer is yes judging by the music and
the smoke all right then I'm out of here
I got blessed little buddy I don't know
what way that's a little disturbing hey
how you doing just a bunch of pretty
lights right tourists waltzing in here
and messing with our delicate mess
walking all over the grass realizing
cosmic energy is just mystic pollution
you know ah I'm the guardian of the
wrong mountain just a bunch of boring
camera flashes here fish can swim as
long as they like but they have gills
you do not stop before you've gone too
far
okay don't know what any that mean did
that fish line make sense I've been
working on my metaphors yeah I think I
kind of get what you mean but I'm just
gonna carry on anyway
I miss my target but I think I'm blessed
now so I can probably go back to the
other side and do a thing a ring about
the mystic bling-bling you have anything
hello
oh no no no okay goodbye sorry about
your loss or I'll be with you in a
second wait you weren't there before
this thing here this face if you will
it opens I remember that much but I
really can't help you much more than
that buddy
alright well I got blessed so I'm gonna
go over here I'm gonna use my blessings
I got my fresh coated blood ready to
rock Lu is it glowing yes it seems to be
glowing there we go look at the shiny
thing step on up and feel the magic you
know I heard that line before but I
didn't turn out too well for me but I'm
gonna trust you this time press space to
activate it whoa holy [ __ ] okay Wow I
made my target haboos key
alrighty man ship it to pesky righty
then
where am I now why am I in the mixture
of stonehedge in the those islands with
the head things I don't know what they
are but you know they go ahead Oh bless
me papa blessed indeed papa and bless
you oh hi good you're here again you've
ignited the second statue you know what
I mean this means you know where you're
going what you're feeling you do not do
you know I do not you're messing with
stuff way out of your league buddy I
feel like I should be making that as
clear as possible no not really I'm not
getting it yeah I'm too old for this all
right then you take your age and go
somewhere else with it cuz I I guess I
got what I needed I'm gonna carry on so
goodbye
I lose the mouth open now is it time to
step inside mouth hmm not quite there
what have you been up to this place has
been making all kinds of wild noise I
think that whatever you're doing is
really screwing with everything up so
why stop now
I still don't know how to get this open
but something around here asks started
making a ton of racket maybe you could
find a way to shut it up so we could
talk easier yeah probably some primary
concern here hey
you bless me touch me I don't know do
something to me I'm ready to go
maybe something up there yeah no it
shows a shortcut for my grappling hook I
sure I'm tired of walking all this way
oh hello hello ski Open Sesame
hi there I did it Wow cool did you do
that
neat anyway there's a shortcut right
through here I just remembered
so neat coincidence say you open this
right when I remembered went ahead
through you know what it's intimidating
but you know I'm a brave boy I'm gonna
go for it
I don't know I'm here and I don't know
I'm walking into a big face but I'm okay
with all of this everything here is cool
what is this ah love the music love the
music uh I see you up there I can't get
to you but you know I'm gonna try it's
got to be a way to get up here all the
bridge Reese Eames to be broken so
there's got to be a way to caboose key
my way on up ah what's over here can I
build a bridge oh I don't think I went
the right way no I did not go the right
way okay goodbye
right so there's got to be something
else over here there's a tree there's a
doer is that this this is that there's
that this maybe I can get a bat Europe
have it have a bit of a bit about okay
almost made it
oh geez almost made that there's
something back here oh hey Heidi Heidi
Heidi ho ho boom okay barely made that
but that can get me somewhere else
ah yes more runes yes please how does
get well that's not what I thought that
was gonna be hey should I touch this I
also see a USB stick 156 Meg's that's
nothing
I find then I can't make that jump
but there's oh ah ah I see you okay
so I'm gonna do that before I go
pressing buttons that I don't know what
do hopefully this is gonna get me
somewhere I need to go oh okay oh geez
oh whoa
okay hello hi should I be here tell me
how I shouldn't be here I'm stuck
no don't push me off what is that what's
that
mysterious stone object okay all right
hello God I keep skittering around on
this I'm just very unstable right now
you made it this far do you expect
applause do you know how long it'll take
to close that mouth you should have
heeded my advice your foolish
determination to push forward will not
get you any sort of reward wise man once
said no stop don't maybe you will end up
a blueberry - I would like that why did
he end up a blueberry
I'm gonna take my mysterious stone
object and [ __ ] on out of here and you
can just eat ten dicks alrighty then I'm
gonna push this mysterious but having
ski
alright cool I got that I'm gonna take
this with me goodbye everybody goodbye
where am I now why am I here oh oh this
seems a lot more sacrificial than I
would have liked who's your new mules
liquid energy holy swang that's a ton of
fuel okey-dokey then still doesn't help
me all right i'ma jump on this thing huh
BAM verbanski how about this thing to
have a bowel skip alrighty then where am
I now there you a thing headwalls
favourite meteor sure would be a shame
if this got thrown into volcano
I completely agree that guy's a douche
Punk yeah nice it's gone forever
screw that guy right right that's what
I'm supposed to do right I mean not
literally
did I go hello alrighty then
ah woo okay glad I got this stolen robot
arm everything else here don't look like
it
oh god that's disorienting but I seem to
be making progress which is good I
suppose
I mean I've destroyed a lot of probably
priceless artifacts on the way Hey
oh you taking a lava bath there
seriously
I'm in the bath whoa what wit but it's
IG items ours I'm a little confused okay
goodbye have a good bath okay Hey look a
button oh cool so I can I can zipline
down no I I don't trust this ah [ __ ]
I know wha Volsky
okay cutters yeah oh whoa
very scary you know trusting things like
that it's gotta assume that the game
program programmed it right Oh whew I
was a little too close for comfort
okay I'll look another bowling pin a few
more of these and I can learn how to
juggle that's what you said for the
other one but I'm gonna throw it in the
lava pit cuz I'm an [ __ ] apparently
alright
Karam bear douche okay have a mare bum
okey-dokey then
still disorienting still weird but I
seem to be doing okay yeah yeah hey hey
uh ski Hey okay okay is this not a thing
is oh there we go here are burski where
am i where am i where am I yeah sure
okay
let's do this Leroy
Thank You Stephanie all righty then huh
boom all right
I wonder if subjecting myself to the
probably constant barrage of radiation
that these things are causing my body to
endure is gonna be good for me in the
long run we oh cool
oh wait I don't know if that was correct
this seems bad Oh what's happening I'm
being shot out of a volcano oh uh how
did that get bored it up already exactly
okay whatever I'm not gonna question it
hello the [ __ ] was there well I guess
things are just I guess dialogues just
gonna be broke now I'm I have no idea I
guess Sam what I've no idea
you can't break like that what right at
the end when I need to find out what the
story is what what do you say okay all
yours just stop is this supposed to
happen I have no idea hello
okay I'm just concerted oh [ __ ] now I
wasn't supposed to happen well oops
go okay I wasn't supposed to go here I
have really
you
[Music]
I have no idea
oh hi uh oh
thanks thank you
Oh Jax I'm just dead they kicked me into
the ocean great am i a blueberry now
am I still part of the boner squad [ __ ]
happened okay anyway that was a trip
holy [ __ ] awesome I have no idea what
happened and I'm already having fun well
that that was the stranger I guess I'm
gonna wait till the end of the credits
to see if there's anything over there
but wow we done here is this is that it
is that all she wrote
am I free to go why did they throw me
into the ocean was there an alternate
ending I do not know but either way I
guess that is the stranger what it
seemed to me is it looked like a student
project and sometimes those get a little
weird but this was weird in a lot of
very good ways and I imagine there's a
lot of things that I did not fully
explore so if you want to play this for
yourself uh put a link down on the
description below thanks again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]